más de cinco años y nueve rondas de
negociación el gobierno alemán confirmó
este viernes que llegó a un acuerdo con
namibia un camino común hacia la
reconciliación en lo que fue escrito por
el ministro de exteriores de alemania
como el capítulo más oscuro en la
historia de estos dos países alemania
reconocerá formalmente que sus tropas
coloniales a principios del siglo 20
cometieron un genocidio contra los
pueblos nama y herrero en lo que
actualmente es el territorio de namibia
alemania también reconocerá su
responsabilidad moral e histórica y
pedirá perdón y como parte de esta
reconciliación las autoridades en berlín
también anunciaron que pondrán a
disposición de namibia un fondo de
desarrollo por valor de unos 1100
millones de euros que sin embargo no
debe entenderse como una compensación se
espera que el ministro de exteriores
alemán ay comas viaje próximamente a
namibia para firmar esta declaración que
también debe ser aprobada por los
parlamentos de ambos países y en el
gesto más importante en el gesto más
simbólico se espera que este año el
presidente
frank walter steinmeier quien es el jefe
de estado viaje a namibia para pedir
oficialmente perdón en nombre del estado
alemán